you'll do your weird guy huh yeah you
know what I thought you were unique
Bobby was when you got when you have
that I know you talked about on stage
when you said you got molested you know
yeah yeah yeah cuz I dealt with the
mentally handicapped we have a bunch of
middlee handicapped by us when I was
growing up and they were wild - what do
you mean Wow loose they had this one man
was a farmer I guess mostly livestock so
yeah you know living crops yeah and he
he had a couple of mental sons and they
called him enols ort ism if somebody had
that ISM that's one day ya had autism
but they didn't want to make it fancy
his autism so French really so you just
have that ISM yeah you know ISM and he
had a couple [ __ ] sons and I don't
mean to say if anybody has [ __ ] I'm
not talking about you I'm talking about
these other [ __ ] people that I knew
when I was going and he uh he had two
[ __ ] sons I would always be on
horseback and so they were yeah because
they were live soccer yeah yeah and
they'd all bro yeah livestock livestock
he's too busy trying to sew so what do
they do to you anybody anything no well
they had one of them eventually got
injured I guess he got injured somehow
and then they got him a bicycle that had
a one of those you know mothers used to
have the bicycle with that baby seat on
the back yeah yeah yeah with that small
baby seat like now they put you in like
this covered Conestoga wagon and like
you're like there's like roll bars and
stuff like I remember back in the day
used to like the kid would just be like
yeah like not even in the mother sites
like yeah yeah good luck back to here
dunno I was in Thailand just real quick
I saw a dude on a moped right he was
wearing this [ __ ] motorcycle helmet
he had a baby on his shoulder baby had
no helmet you might as well just take
the helmet officer and just tie your
baby to your head use the baby as the
helmet right I mean yeah it does fait
practice right
right we don't put a helmet on a baby
that's risky right so one of these guys
got up was mentally challenging he got a
bicycle eventually and they gave him the
bike had a like a child mother's baby
seat on the back yeah and I had never
met anybody that was gay they didn't
have a lot of gay people in our area and
if they did we didn't know about until
we're older where did you grow up in
Louisiana and they didn't come by and
also you know when you grow up in like a
rural area like nobody really cares if
somebody's gay it's not like they're
running around like they don't have a
gay pride parade you know because only
two gay dads
if they meet up in the street they're
probably just gonna [ __ ] a little you
know yeah they're not gonna put together
a whole parade for everybody so but
people said that this man was a
homosexual you know and they didn't have
and everybody's like wow and they said
that they said he had a husband like a
little husband that left him that he's
just sit in that back seat so there was
always like a ton of not remorse really
I don't know what the feeling is but
when you saw this man go by you were
like all that's so sad that his little
husband that it's remorse yeah and it
was just sad you know cuz you're like oh
this guy had a little husband that left
him and so I believe everything you're
saying cuz we watched a documentary
called mommy dead and dearest and
everyone's from Louisiana but like in
the Bayou remember how they talked yeah
yeah yeah III think that like it's just
simpler you just learn things like in a
different way you know so like I'm sure
like you're in a small town the two
Gators people know them right right so
there's not like it I think in the media
when you see like you know Republicans
talk right and they talk about you know
that they don't believe in you know gay
riots or whatever right that's just in
the media but I think in small towns
they accept them right a hundred percent
like that's the crazy thing like the
only time anybody ever put anybody on
television from my area was when like
they needed somebody who'd seen a an
alien or something yeah yeah otherwise
these people are mostly doing good stuff
you know yeah it's just like they always
go to like one or two spots and pick out
the
Yeah right and I think they'd do it for
almost everything yeah but um you never
saw an alien growing up let me thank you
know one of my buddies died he was on
oxycontin and he choked to death on a
some type of a meat bone or something I
don't know but it was chicken fowl I
thought after he died that he came to
see me a couple times so not alien that
you're talking about go tell ghost and
you're talking about the paranormal
you're talking about not answer estriol
not extra trash
so you he when he came back that he
looked like an alien or did he look like
it was on the porch she was outside as
himself I felt like it was him but he
seemed a little bit more you know kind
of Randi than he used to be a little
more active yeah all right well cuz you
get a little bit I bet you once you're
dead you're like oh I'm free you know
that's your Amistad man you're out of
your body you know you're about do you
believe in that in afterlife I do
because we came here like people always
like you think you go to like a magical
place in the sky you know and
everybody's just sitting around and
[ __ ] drinking rocket sauce and doing
magic you know yeah and I'm like look
where I'm at now bro I'm in the middle
of all the [ __ ] dirt yeah this
happened yeah this the only proof I have
so do I think it's something like this
could happen again yeah I have to think
that so when people like you think you
go to a crate a place where this is a
bunch of other people that you don't
know and like if you're talking about
heaven you know yeah and everybody's
doing good and I'm like yeah we just
like here but everybody would be doing
good you know yeah yeah yeah so I base
it on it's almost more like
reincarnation a little bit yeah I you
know I don't necessarily like geared
towards it's always believing in things
that are factual but Wow oh but I do
believe in like sort of like the
paranormal stuff because when you live
in a big city like this you're so all
your senses are drowned out constantly
by the noise of traffic by people around
you is there's always chaotic but when I
go back to the provincial area
in the Philippines you do sense
something different there you hear
things more you feel things more yeah
and I always get sort of a sense of like
that paranormal stuff when I'm back
there but never here in LA so I can it's
called boredom no it's not boredom yeah
you think goes come here yeah
I wake up no this is what happens la I
wake up a [ __ ] I gotta go here I gotta
go to Starbucks I gotta go to the iPad
store get my things screen fixed you me
and I'm gonna go see uh Joe some friend
yeah I was in a [ __ ] vape store yeah
why and then you go to an a meeting that
I got two shows to do yeah you got [ __ ]
to do over there you wake up there's
nothing to do oh I see a ghost yeah I
see it yeah it's like something like Oh
what are we gonna do today right Zak
there's nothing to do yes your mind and
right am I not right babe or no no okay
I just you kind of reinforce what I was
saying which is you don't allow yourself
to feel anything because you pack your
day with so much and your feelings here
it's hard to get your feelings have no
space here like I can't even feel that
much here you know like I'm far more I
noticed once as soon as I get outside of
the city limits I'm far more and you
know I'm not trying to be profane buddy
erect big feeling again yes my life has
feeling again like I don't see how
people have any there's no room for your
feelings here there's just no you can't
relax I can't anyway maybe if you were
brought up in this type of environment
yeah I'm like that in New York really
yeah if I'm waking one like when I wake
up in a hotel room in New York with all
the noise and all that stuff
I could probably sleep for four hours
Wow am I just walking around right I
just cannot sleep hmm it's just if
there's excitement in the air or the
[ __ ] to do I don't know one time I was
in [ __ ] New York and I meet I don't
know how I ran into it I ran into Maz
Jobrani hmm he's like Indian or some
[ __ ] yeah what is his uh Pakistani or
whatever and he goes he goes hey dude
you want to go to a Moroccan like
nightclub but it's like an invite-only
and it's illegal I want to go I want to
go those two things Moroccan illegal I
have to go
okay alleyway down these steps through a
red door we walk in and then there's
like a fire right and there's people
with bongo drums the tribal smoking like
see yes
smoking things and people are dancing
right and I just started I start dancing
too because I didn't know what the [ __ ]
to do I was scared yeah right because
mas started to I think I'm ed was there
too oh I'm and that's what to me New
York is you know so when I'm in LA I
feel relaxed mm-hmm right and if I go to
like wherever you're from I probably go
into coma yeah yeah I probably go in a
coma and never wake up again
[Music]